[Music]
we are playing black
and this game won't quite push us over
1500 but it'll come very close
okay d4 good
all right let's play
let's deviate a little bit from the
queen's gamut let's go knight f6 i'm i'm
feeling a little bit more adventurous
okay e3 okay so basically e3 is a call
in uh this you know here it makes
it it makes sense to go d5 and transpose
to
a queen's pawn game setup
all right c3 this is a traditional kali
setup
now there's two ways to play this for
white why can play f4 and go for the
reverse stone wall
or white can go bishop d3 and go for the
kali but c3 is inaccurate
and it's important to detect these
subtleties in the opening so why is it
inaccurate because it turns out that
white should actually go bishop d3
straight away
by going c3 white is giving us an extra
opportunity to do what
to develop a piece onto a particularly
nice square now we can play bishop f5
and in the in the event of bishop d3
well that bishop trade favors
favors black the whole point of the kali
is to preserve the light square bishop
not to trade it
now in fact we don't have to rush with
bishop takes d3
and we have a very nice positional move
which i think some of you might not see
intuitively i think a lot of you might
be thinking about bishop g6 but
there is another way of preserving the
tension
and offering
a change of pawn structure which i
really i mean the resulting pawn
structure i really like
so g6 is close but not g6
but rather e6 yeah so e6 is the move i i
enjoy here
and in the event of a trade we've got
this massive massive oh there we go
excellent i'm glad i'm glad he took
because now i can explain what to do in
the structure okay queen d3 that's a
good move
we need to be careful tactically
tactically we need to be careful for one
move because if we go g6
uh those with a sharp tactical eye might
see that queen b5 check is
a threat
for king the king of the pawn same after
knight e4 there's queen b5 check so we
have to play queen d7
to defend both at the same time
now again we need to be careful for a
couple of moves the knight is coming to
e5
now you might go you can go knight c6
but if if you'll remember i don't
particularly like to block
the c pawn in queen's pawn game openings
so i would much prefer to go bishop d6
here
and if 95 we just take it and then
for example go 94 that's not a good
trade for white
okay
castles we also castle
and then we can play rook e8 just to
prevent just to prevent 95 and clamp
even further down on the center
and this is going to be the whole
zen of our strategy is the fact that
it's hard for white to free himself
good players know how to handle these
positions with white but
you know i think in the 14 1500 range
people aren't very good at dealing with
being cramped
that's a good move actually bishop a3 is
the idea this is one of the best ideas
against this setup
okay well what are we going to do now
well we can make several improving moves
i mentioned rookie eight
i also like the possibility of
centralizing the knight on e4 that's
pretty self-explanatory
we could go c5 at some point but in fact
i prefer to put the pawn on c6 i feel
like c5 defeats the purpose of this idea
remember that when you have a clamp on
the center like this opening up the
center
really goes against what it is you're
trying to do it gives your opponent more
breathing room
so
i like either rookie 8 or 94
but i think the most flexible move here
is rookie 8
and if he goes bishop a3 i'll be pretty
impressed
ricky h is getting getting the rook on a
good square
no g6 is not bad you could certainly
throw in g6
but it's also not really necessary our
queen is doing a totally fine job of
defending pawn
okay so is knight e4 still possible is
it still good
can he take
it is it is absolutely still good
because if he takes it we take with a
fork
then i think that we'll play c6 in order
to protect
the d5 pawn
and you might be asking that what do we
do with the b89 we'll figure out a spot
for the position is closed we don't need
to develop all of our pieces at once
we'll figure out a route for the night
for instance if we play pawn c6 we can
go knight a6 back to c7 i'm sure you've
seen that particular way of developing
before
okay let's go
c6 reinforcing the d5 pawn
the other approach we could take is the
queen has done its job on d7 now it just
looks awkward there
we can move the queen
aside to a different square and then
open up the d7 square for the knight
that to me is is more palatable than
going knight a6
now where should you move the queen
we've already talked about this concept
the primary point of moving the queen is
to open up the d7 square for the knight
but if you're already moving the queen
you might as well try to accomplish
something else
remember that white's king in such
positions is not the safest piece you
know the white is really passive so if
we actually start an attack
we could
potentially uh you know that could be a
way to
way to play so i like queen e6 yeah
queen e7 or queen e6 but i particularly
like queen e6 because
the queen could swing to h6 you could do
a queen lift
i'm not saying we will i'm saying that
we might do it under a slightly
different set of circumstances
so this brings me to an important point
i'll talk more about this after the game
just because we're playing positionally
doesn't mean that you can't attack i
think some people have a misconception
about this which is that oh and in this
situation i need to play positionally
but you can do both at the same time you
could play positionally
and and then decide to at the right
moment transition to an attack against
the king that's totally normal c4
in fact i think that's what we're going
to do right now i think we've fully
improved our position right we've put
our knight on a great square we've
developed our pieces let's go what are
we waiting for time for the queen lifts
win h6
now we're not worried about the trade
the trade opens up the c file but if you
notice we have all of the squares on the
c file well protected
so i'm not worried about his queen
infiltrating it's not possible we're
defending them
oh this is great for us
this this just closes things down even
further
and it unties our hands for kingside
action
and now
stuff i mean winter is coming for his
king trust me
g5 might run into g3 okay goes g3 anyway
now in such situations when you're
attacking like this you need to think in
terms of drawbacks what is the drawback
of the move g3 and can we explain it
the answer is well you tell me what's
the drawback of that move
it weakens age three
so
let's put our monkey hats on our monkey
brain on can we exploit it
well
yeah i think we can right we can put a
queen on h3
why is that good because once we have a
queen on h3
we can then bring this knight to g4 and
that creates a situation which i'm sure
you've seen before
where essentially white is totally
helpless
and and this one
flimsy knight on f3
is saving white from death in addition
you might be familiar with ideas of
sacrificing on g3 in certain positions
although here
it's not as appetizing
so there's multiple approaches here we
could also lift our rook to h6
but the best thing we could do here is
is to go knight d knight df6 knight
knight g4 now you might say well why do
we need to play queen hd why can't we
just go knight f6 immediately and you
can you can certainly go knight df6 here
the problem is that white sometimes can
go h4 and
keep our queen out of of h3 is it
necessary to respond to this movement
somewhere or we can continue
accomplishing our plan
it's not a terrible move if he follows
it up correctly i'll put it that way now
let's continue knight df6
we take a second to
to see if this does anything it really
doesn't
and then we continue
knight df3 we play knight shoot for
anyway and white's position totally
collapses
okay
well we could play knight g4 anyway
although i guess we give up f5 there but
it doesn't matter as i'll show you guys
the reality is that
the f5 pawn is totally unimportant here
and this leads me to a very important
topic of discussion which is these
situations in general with the queen on
h3 and the knight on g4 are important
it's important to understand them from a
tactical standpoint
the question is what do we want to
accomplish here with black
what is our objective how do how are we
going to win this game
well we're going to win this game by
distracting
the knight from f3
right we need to get this knight off of
f3 somehow
okay well you might consider how you can
do that you can really only do that with
a knight
uh and as you guys are correctly
indicating
as soon as you know what to do you see
the move it's knight g5
now our opponent is playing very
resiliently he can go 91 he can make it
difficult for us okay no he didn't make
it difficult for us
made it easy for us
made it easy for us but it was already
over let me start from the end what
would happen if white goes knight g to
e1
so
in such situations it's also important
to be flexible right one of the
objectives
is to get rid of the knight on f3 but
there is also a brute force approach
we can ultimately crash through by
overloading the h2 pawn and there's an
idea that didn't go anywhere
that idea is just to play rookie six the
knight's chilling on g5
and if queen takes f5 happens
well the simplest win is knight takes f3
knight takes f3 and again switching back
to the other idea noticing the alignment
of the queen and the the knight and
going north f6 and this simply wins the
night followed by checkmate
but uh
if he doesn't take on f5 then we go rook
h6 and knight takes h2 and there's one
important
or not important but there's one cool
idea
knight takes h2 knight takes chief oh i
guess
i guess this is made but
i've seen cases where people drop the
knight back to f3 this is also a cool
tactic in queen h1
this is all very easy it's like target
practice because there's no no counter
play
that was pretty uh pretty
straightforward so c3 is not a great
move
straight away it allows us to get the
bishop out to f5
and hopefully
through the lens of this game you were
able to understand why i like this setup
why i like these pawns
it's like a marotzi bind shifted over
and ultimately i think that
our opponent played well initially i
think this was good this was good the
way that white needs to handle this is
to really open up the position as
quickly as possible b3
was even this was good this is where our
opponent started going wrong now as i
said i think the correct move is bishop
a3 here
the point is that this bishop on d6 is
an excellent piece it's guarding e5
and it's also aiming at the king so by
playing bishop a3 while it's offering a
trade
black can't really do anything about it
we would have played sorry no c6 doesn't
work that one is a pawn we could play g6
here
and then white trades
and i still think black is slightly
better but if white goes c4
and then knight c3
i think that white's got a pretty
reasonable position here and it's
certainly not going to result in
checkmate
no but here's the thing is savage muffin
e5 is not a weak square that's an
illusion
you shouldn't be afraid of this
because if you look very carefully
you can push the f pawn up to f7 up to
f6 and chase the knight away
so for instance
we could play knight f to d7 and if y
goes f4 we go f6
and not only does this chase the knight
away but
now the e3 pawn is extremely weak
and we can start doubling rooks on on
the e4 again an example of how double
pawns can be a good thing
okay so
so for that reason you don't need to
rush with the move knight c6
but you can't
sorry congested
in certain situations you could even
consider taking with a pawn
in order to defend the e5 square so this
is not out of the question this this
would be interesting
okay
so knight e4
good move
and this is where white gets to pass
rook 81. remember i said that this is
typical for this level for players of
this level just sort of defaulting to
these kinds of moves but again
you know the way agm would think about
this is white doesn't have time
you know to bring pieces into the center
and to make meaningless rook moves you
need to open stuff up and get play
and so i would be inclined to play c4
asap here although it might already not
help
this is a very nasty position for black
for white
but i would consider something like this
and then maybe something like this at
least trying to orchestrate some sort of
kind of play on the queen side
so
rook 81 queen e6 opening up the square
for the night
let me get it there now to our
opponent's credit he did end up playing
c4 but it was already too late already
the position is dire
and um
i honestly don't really know what white
should do here i think white's already
close to being lost
now in such positions there's an
interesting
first of all c5 is the decisive mistake
for sure because now with the queen side
being close that's it i mean white's
just busted on the king's side
definitely c takes d5 is best
and one uh way that you can try to
defend such positions it doesn't work
here
is basically to play knight takes c4 f
takes e4 and 95.
this is a good a good move against like
a 50 and 1600 because a lot of players
in that rating range would
automatically
sort of take twice and
well why is this bad because white's
whites managed to trade all of these
pieces
the attack is no longer that dangerous
and in fact white has massive counter
play even if i didn't have that move
white would have this massive outpost
for the rook
and a lot of play along the defile white
would have a very solid position
actually
so what would be the correct approach in
this position for black
black does have an incredibly nasty move
yeah the move is f6 of course
knight g4 is forced otherwise it's made
and now queen h5 and white is in huge
trouble anyway
but just remember this concept of
basically giving up one or two pawns in
order to get rid of the attack and force
your opponent to win a different kind of
position
i've shown you examples of that yeah
once this happens we go queen h3
and the game is over go knight f6 knight
g4 just very consecutive simple
attacking chess
and then the
small tactic knight g5
over straining white's defensive
resources too passive
and uh that's all she wrote
short short and sweet ladies and
gentlemen
okay well i hope you enjoyed the games
we are at 1500
and i'll see you guys see you guys later
thanks for hanging out bye
[Music]